[Musique]
xavier mouche ou m'a longtemps était
privé de marché sur ses rives où venait
pêcher ses ancêtres
on a un cimetière de notre famille ici
dans ce tas rivière lé la descente de
mumbai qui auraient été jetés à l'eau à
la rif l'année par six seulement
placé sous tutelle des services sociaux
à l'âge de 8 ans cet enfant de la nation
algonquine anishinabeg a connu 14
familles d'accueil en disant je me
retire beaucoup par ici un isolant
plutôt pour prier
un parcours chaotique au gré de
décisions d'agents de l'état qu'ils ont
des racines et de sa culture et de sa
communauté comme beaucoup d'autres
selon un jugement du tribunal canadien
des droits de la personne depuis les
années 90 plus de 160 mille enfants
autochtones ont ainsi été victimes d'une
discrimination systématique par les
services à l'enfance et à la famille des
premières nations une agence d'état
canadiennes
[Musique]
autres victimes devenu un symbole
national de ce système discriminatoire
le petit jordan river anderson cinq ans
mort d'une maladie rare en 2005 sans
avoir pu quitter l'hôpital de sa courte
vie
[Musique]
jordan n'a jamais rejoint la maison
familiale
empêché pendant trois ans par un conflit
entre gouvernements provincial et
fédéral pour savoir qui paierait la
facture des soins à domicile son décès
avait créé un électrochoc
mais malgré l'adoption d'un principe
juridique portant son nom les failles du
système ont persisté
un traumatisme bien connue des réserves
autochtones comme ici au lac simon
territoire de la nation anishnabe et
point de départ d'un combat judiciaire
de plus de 15 ans contre les dérives des
services sociaux à l'enfance de l'état
canadien le convoque les promène ici au
québec ou au canada
et la longue haleine une russe mais on a
des avis qui sont en mesure de nous
accompagner et ces personnes là sont des
vraiment des gens qui nous comprennent
qu'ils sont près de nous il nous
accompagne dans nos démarches pour
justement démontré que nos enfants sont
importants qu'ils ont des lois qu'ils
ont le droit de dette avec leurs parents
dans leur culture d'al aridha
ces six mois
si on nous enlève ça qu'est ce qu'on a
dit après avoir fait appel de sa
condamnation en justice le gouvernement
fédéral a finalement négocier une sortie
de crise en proposant une indemnisation
record
40 milliards de dollars dont une moitié
ira aux victimes et l'autre moitié
servira à réformer le système
aucune somme d'argent ne peut réparer
les torts subis par les enfants des
premières nations où le rendre les
années en famille les années d'amour
perdues parce qu'ils ont connu la
souffrance d'être séparés de leur
famille de leur communauté et de leur
culture
les injustices historiques exige des
réparations historique notre objectif
commun est de parvenir à un règlement
qui puisse être envoyé aux familles dès
que possible
qualifiée d'historique par l'association
des premières nations l'entente de
principe doit encore être entérinée par
les tribunaux
un changement de cap louable d'ottawa
accueilli avec prudence trop de
promesses n'ont pas été tenues rappelle
les critiques de justin trudeau après
une année ponctuée par les découvertes
de centaines de tombes d'enfants
victimes au 19è et au xxème siècle
d'internement forcé en pensionnat
autochtone un génocide culturel admis
par la cour suprême en 2015 un système
destructeur dont le père de xavier
mouche ou m'a été victime avant son fils
voici les documents de la cour fédérale
en mon nom xavier motion son seul
souhait que sa victoire en justice ne
s'arrête pas un chèque du gouvernement
site historique car c'est
totalement de l'ingéniosité
de fass emilie sera interdit de
parler sa propre langue j'imagine que la
nouvelle génération que
sont aujourd'hui qui viennent vers nous
ils sont plus aptes à bien diriger cet
argent dit ça pourrait changer signe des
temps qui changent au lac simon le
conseil de la nation anishnabe a lancé
son propre service juridique de
protection de la jeunesse un modèle
depuis repris et imité par plusieurs
autres communautés autochtones au canada